here's a simple sight skinny ties I've
opened up dev tools in another window so
when I resize this you'll see the
resolution show up right here and like
any responsible responsive designer I'm
starting with a small mobile design this
one looks pretty clean
I'll start expanding and at 480 pixels I
hit the first breakpoint there are now 2
columns there are bow ties and pocket
squares next to each other okay and at
larger than 690 pixels there are our
three columns nice
once the viewport is larger than 915
pixels all the fonts get bigger which is
a pretty nice touch I also noticed a few
other small changes as the page was
getting larger after you watch this
video maybe you can check out skinny
ties and try to find them I also took a
look at CNN coms new layout this one is
a bit more complicated once again I am
starting small notice the hamburger icon
in the top right hand corner clicking on
it makes the nav bar show up that's
pretty nice also notice that there are
social media icons underneath this main
story I've expanded the page larger than
725 pixels across and now these social
media icons are gone unless you hover
over this would be something that would
be called a minor breakpoint which isn't
a huge page layout change but there's
still something slightly different I've
expanded the page past 800 pixels wide
and I see that the hamburger icon is
gone there's more room at the top of the
page so as a result the navigation menu
options are just showing up here larger
than 935 pixels the layout really
changes with the extra screen real
estate a few sentences about the main
story show up over here and all of this
description is now on the right notice
the social media icons are once again
showing by default larger than the
classic 960 pixel width the new screen
real estate is being taken up by other
top stories for today
and I found one more small breakpoint
larger than 1024 pixels and AD shows up
all in all not a bad design so now it's
time for you to think about breakpoints